three weeks ago the covert inquiry began
an independent and public examination of
the way the UK dealt with coronavirus
it's being led by baroness Hallett a
retired court of appeal judge and this
stage is looking very specifically at
how prepared the country was to deal
with a Public Health crisis of this
magnitude so far we've heard from the
former Prime Minister David Cameron
former Chancellor George Osborne at the
chief medical officer sir Chris witty on
Tuesday however it was the turn of the
former Health secretary Matt Hancock I
am profoundly sorry for the impact that
had I'm profoundly sorry for each death
that has occurred and I also understand
why for some it will be hard to take
that apology from me I understand that I
get it
um but it is honest and heartfelt and
I'm not very good at talking about my
emotions and how I feel
um but that is honest and true now that
very public statement of Contrition was
met with anger in private from some of
the families of those who lost their
lives of which more later but at its
core Mr Hancock's testimony made clear
that he feels the government's response
the pandemic Doctrine they chose to
follow was flawed from the off
I'm Neil Patterson Welcome To The Sky
News Daily
now whilst the politicians are fond of
seeing that they were on the front line
of the response to covet in reality it
was of course the care workers the
hospital ancillary staff the nurses and
the doctors later I'll be speaking to
the man who was chair of the British
Medical Association during the pandemic
it's absolutely the moral right thing to
do to have an inquiry that is properly
objective and that gets to the bottom of
how the UK responded to what has been
the greatest Public Health crisis since
the Inception of the NHS let's not
forget that more than two hundred
thousand of our citizens lost their
lives which is the highest in the whole
of Western Europe
but we begin with Sky's Health
correspondent Ashish Joshi speaking to
us from the inquiry itself
so this is going to be a wide-ranging
public inquiry most importantly to learn
lessons to make this country as safe and
as secure as it can be for future
pandemics we're hearing from a pretty
impressive cash list already David
Cameron George Osborne Chris witty
cropping up we've been hearing from the
health secretary for large parts of
course of that period at Matt Hancock
and according to him when asked you know
where we prepared enough for this
pandemic he was apparently informed way
back when that this country was the best
prepared in the world didn't turn out
that uh to be fair to Matt Hancock he
did say it didn't turn out like that his
line of defense was to say I inherited A
system that was flawed he kept using the
word doctrinal what he was trying to say
Neil is that there are so many things
wrong within the the health system in
this country which does not equip it for
a fast-moving pandemic he said we were
not prepared to scale up testing our
Diagnostics wasn't wasn't capable we
were just not in a position to deal with
the pandemic because we were too heavily
focused not on stopping the spread of
covid-19 but we were too focused on
dealing with the Fallout what do we do
with mass casualties and there are
hundreds of thousands what do we do when
our hospitals are overrun so in other
words we're looking at the tail end of
the pandemic once it started and not
with how do we stop people becoming
infected how do we stop the spread of
any disease or any infection so he said
that's why we were not in a position to
deal with a pandemic effectively Matt
Hancock kept saying all the way through
I tried to do the best I can but it's an
inherently flawed system and he was
asked by Hugo Keith Casey that the covid
inquiry lawyer the lead Council again
and again and again remind us Mr Hancock
who do you work for yes it's the
Department of Health remind us Mr
Hancock what is your title Secretary of
State for health therefore Ergo why did
you not do something about it before the
pandemic hit and we didn't actually get
the answer the definitive answer I mean
it's interesting when you were referring
to my Hancock's answers today you used
the phrase line of defense because in
essence that is exactly what it is isn't
it Matt Hancock making the case that
Matt Hancock wasn't wrong but but as you
see he identifies these problems with
pandemic preparedness he also took the
job in July 2018 if he was aware of this
could not something have been done and
as you say on that point I didn't hear
very much by the way of counter argument
by Mr hanco and I've been speaking to
the bereaved families were here and this
is why they're furious with him they
said he came here with this line of
defense and then he elected to promote
all the good things he did during the
pan them and he said you know he didn't
listen to the World Health
organization's advice he imposed
quarantine on air Travelers arriving
from countries where covid-19 was
spreading it was him who instigated the
vaccine procurement so it's all about
the things Matt Hancock did right
despite this flawed Health System we did
get a recognition from Matt Hancock that
the pandemic plan that they were using
was ultimately dated all the way back to
2011 we also got an acceptance that No
Deal planning for brexit within the
Department of Health actually had an
effect on our ability to do with the
pandemic this is module one module one
deals with the years leading up to 2020
and it is I think accepted fact now from
all of the witnesses who have come
including sir Professor Chris witty and
Sir Patrick Valance that pandemic
planning certainly was impacted by
brexit and that's because they wanted to
make sure the government wanted to make
sure that it was fully focused on brexit
the supply lines the availability of
medicine and everything else just in
terms of of this argument that Matt
Hancock is it is making about pandemic
Doctrine the idea that we were far too
focused on dealing with a pandemic
rather than preventing a pandemic I mean
he is right isn't he I mean he he is
absolutely correct isn't he to identify
that perhaps we were not as quick into
lockdown because we weren't ready to
move into lockdown as many of the
medical professionals were telling us we
we should have been doing yes David
Cameron the the former prime minister
said that he'd been sounding warnings as
early as 2016 because that's one he had
been advised by his own health
professionals so therefore
health professionals including the World
Health Organization and our own experts
here in this country would have been
aware that pandemics Global Health
emergencies come in cycles and that
there should have been effective uh
planning for any such emergency but what
has transpired over the past weeks of
evidence here listening to The Experts
all of that planning and preparedness
was focused much too heavily on
influenza and an influence pandemic and
that we were told that's because that is
what's happened in the past and and you
just can't predict covid-19 did you
detect any Contrition on the part of
Matt Hancock I mean the reason I ask Ash
is we should not forget this was a
health secretary who was forced out of
his post in utter disgrace I did hear
him say you know I am profoundly sorry
for the huge error in Doctrine but
that's not what him apologizing for his
actions that's him saying others made
incorrect decisions I had to respond
this one's not on megov absolutely spot
on and that came across loud and clear
to the bereaved families that they were
here to to to see how Matt Hancock when
he arrived this morning holding
photographs and and pictures of their
deceased loved ones he apologized and he
said and I know that they will find that
especially difficult to hear from me in
particular so he knows that he has got
to go some way to build any Bridges with
the bereaved families who are here but
not not only did he apologize in the
hearing on on the public record and they
couldn't do anything they couldn't react
to that apology during the hearing after
the hearing was over Matt Hancock went
into a room where the bereaved families
were gathered he went in there to
apologize I spoke to one of these
bereaved family members and she said we
were shocked we could not believe he had
come over to speak to us
Hancock approached us and I weren't
having any of it I was like no
don't don't you even think about it and
I turned my back on him
and he was looking for forgiveness
but I said you'll be forever looking for
forgiveness because you're not going to
get it off the bereavement they all turn
their backs on him and they refuse to
accept his apology and I think one of
the bereaved family members even swore
at him certainly there was
not an altercation but it was a very
strong exchange if Matt Hancock was in
any doubt that his evidence today was
not what they wanted to hear they wanted
to hear a minister explain things went
wrong I could have perhaps listened to
advisors put in place some measures to
protect more people they didn't hear
that and they did not accept his apology
a complaint that has long been made of
this covert inquiry is that it simply
isn't giving enough attention to the
views of the families of those who lost
their lives the medical profession had
those suffering from covet at the heart
of everything they did during those
covert years shouldn't the inquiry be
doing exactly the same Dr Chand nagpo
was chairman of the BMA Council from
2017 to 2022 and thus represented the
medical profession during the covert
pandemic
I think it's really important to hear
the real experiences of those who are
affected sadly we cannot hear from those
who have uh passed away but we can hear
the experiences of those close to them
we can hear the experiences of the
issues they faced uh the limitations in
in the way in which the nation may not
have been able to protect them and I can
tell you as a doctor I'm a GP and I
recall very very clearly when in March
we were seeing every single day
notifications of deaths in a in a way I
had never seen before in my life as a GP
I've been a GP for three decades and
what was also striking for me was how
many of those names of people who had
died were of ethnic minority origin
because I I practiced in North London
and there were issues like that that
really highlighted at the you know at
its heart how we were not protecting
people we were looking after care homes
where we had residents who who are
getting infected many of them sadly not
surviving talk to me about those those
lessons doctor that you feel have
already been learned much of this stage
of the inquiry is focusing on
preparedness or frankly the lack thereof
not just in central government but
within the Health Service itself I mean
just take us back to those early days
and the lessons that you yourself learn
I mean it must have felt fairly chaotic
well first of all I remember doing
interviews at the time in December 2019
January 2020 so this is before covet hit
our Shores and I remember you know the
fact that we had an NHS that was already
in crisis you know we had about 10 000
doctor vacancies about a hundred
thousand vacancies across the NHS we had
record weights in terms of ambulance
response times we had record weights for
cancer treatment months before covet hit
us so we didn't have an NHS that was
able to cope with even a surge of normal
winter pressures
let alone a pandemic and I think one of
the key lessons is that we can no longer
as a nation or we should no longer as a
nation accept a health service that runs
each year on a deficit of infrastructure
of people and hospital beds and
Community facilities such as in general
practice and we were not therefore
prepared in terms of infrastructure the
second of course when you have any sort
of infection a pandemic in particular
you need to be prepared for this um
widespread infection that it literally
takes over a whole nation
the other part about any pandemic is you
need to control a spread of infection
and again we didn't have the testing
capacity and one of the reasons we
didn't have the testing capacity is that
not only did we not have enough hospital
beds enough GP facilities enough staff
we also had run down a public health
infrastructure which had actually had
cuts of around 400 million pounds in the
previous decade now the other thing the
government didn't do was recognize sadly
that when you have any sort of pandemic
it will not affect everyone equally I
mean Dr Nicole Am I Wrong to detect
perhaps just a touch of frustration in
your voice there that there was
empirical evidence about what was
happening within ethnic minority
communities here in this country that
the government either didn't pay enough
attention to or ignored yes there is
frustration you know it baffles me
because I would have thought that the
protecting the nation protecting its
citizens protecting those that care for
others should have been
not just a moral responsibility but it
is the responsibility of government to
look after its people and I couldn't
fathom out why there was this tardiness
and in fact you know I think that the
that that looking back this is something
that should never be repeated uh we need
one this is one of the key lessons that
should never be repeated listen to the
the former Health secretary Matt Hancock
giving evidence to the to the inquiry we
at least have a slightly clearer picture
of his take on what went on in the
run-up to 2019-2020 and in his mind he
arrived at the Department of Health and
was told we are the best prepared in the
world for pandemics he then went on to
say he discovered subsequently that that
was not the case it is understandable
that you feel frustrated I wondered if
you and your colleagues might also feel
pretty angry given that it was you that
was out there on the front line dealing
with patients during the midst of this
pandemic and none of the work which
could have been done in the five years
leading up to it I had been I think the
inquiry will I hope be able to
demonstrate whether this was actually
all down to a lack of planning or was it
was it a lack of implementing some of
the key messages from those uh pandemic
plans look I can't speak for Matt
Hancock who was Secretary of State at
the time all I can say is that the
government ultimately had a
responsibility to take the right action
uh in the earlier stages of the pandemic
in fact don't forget that we in the UK
had had had Advanced knowledge we saw
what was going on in Spain and Italy and
therefore you we we had a head start in
being able to to know what needed to
happen and in spite of that when we
actually saw covet hit our Shores it
felt like we didn't know how to to
address it we were told that that we had
the facilities to contain the virus but
unfortunately we realized the reality
was far removed from those original
assurances so there were these
incongruities of the UK's approach to
containing the virus in the early stages
but in fact if the reason was because we
didn't have the the facilities because
we didn't have the stock parts and I
think it would have been important to
have been honest with the Nation about
those limitations
thank you doctor now quickly back to you
Ashish and look this inquiry is going to
take years to conclude I'm just
wondering if perhaps we haven't learned
the lesson from not learning lessons
during the pandemic do we not need
interim conclusions I mean all it takes
is is one mutation after all and we're
right back where we started there will
be
module and then it will be up to the
government to take the recommendations
of each module and action them as they
say fit yeah because like you said Neil
we don't know how soon or how far away
the next uh Global Health Emergency is
and and the one acceptance from everyone
who's spoken at this inquiry so far is
things didn't go as well as they could
have done and lessons do need to be
learned my thanks to Dr Chan nagpal and
Ashish Joshi this episode was produced
by soil Apparition our editor was Daniel
weeks trulifier